dr brian keating
alan my friend it's great to be here my
first in-person podcast since the
pandemic began
quite a quite an honor good to be here
so pumped into the impossible
interviewing many of the greatest minds
also professing
passing along the physics knowledge
that's right the astrophysics knowledge
also with the cosmic microwave
background
the origins of the universe man that's
right
the biggest picture topics it's you know
trying to get the next generation that
shirt you're wearing there
inspire the next generation look at that
that is some serious stuff
i have the matching underwear and we can
show that later
that's the behind the scenes stuff
literally if you go to subscribe to
brian's channel
and then if you go to his only fans page
he has his big bang
underwear
actually they were asking me this i was
doing a documentary earlier today i was
telling you and they're like where did
the name big bang come from and i'm like
do you really want me to say
because it could be a little bit you
know for pg-13 i know your audience
keeps it clean but
yeah it's it's funny it's it's funny all
the all the puns
there's a lot of bad puns you can make
in our industry you know yeah
yeah exactly but then also
authoring losing the nobel prize as well
and
also you have the analysis of this
astrophysical data
that's coming from the observatory and
array in
chile and so there's that and so
there's a lot of funding that's went
into that and so that's exciting
and then there's the arthur c clarke
it's the center for human imagination
that's right yeah yeah i like to have a
diverse
portfolio of intellectual interests
because
and i think that's what makes life
interesting you just do one thing you
get kind of
as robert heinlein said specialization
is for insects you don't want to just do
one thing
for me you know i've always felt a lot
of respect for my friends that do the
theoretical physics or math
even chemistry i was inspired by isaac
asimov as a kid
obviously galileo and people like that
but stephen hawking
brian greene lisa randall those kinds of
names
but they're all like theoreticians
they're all theoretical uh
astrophysicists cosmologists what have
you
and i said where is the place for
someone who talks about experiments
actually building this stuff
hands-on high-tech cameras sensors
development data analysis cryogenics
you know taking these things to the
bottom of the planet to the south pole
to the top of the andes mountains
i want to be that voice i wanted to seek
out you know kind of a different niche
not to be too over specialized but then
broaden it out with conversations with
the brightest minds as i say in the
multiverse
and i get to do that i'm trying to
create the channel that's basically a
free university
you know because i'm i'm a state
employee here in california
and i feel i want to give back to the
public i want to give back and create
the university i wish existed
when i was a kid that you won't have to
pay any college tuition debt from
and uh you get to attend in your pajamas
so that's pretty fun
yeah it gives me a lot of a lot of gr uh
you know gratification
to do that yeah i love the
component of being so
driven to be a polymath and to
pull from many different fields in many
of the greatest minds and then also to
distill what is learned
in ways that is applicable for the
masses
practically to
apply to augment their lives and then i
love the other
component which is building up these
catalogs of interviews with really
thought provoking minds and then
have that be like on all of these
different interviewer channels it's just
massive catalogs of hundreds if not a
thousand or more of these interviews
with these great minds for people like
you said in their pajamas
when they look up a key term about
biology or about consciousness or
whatever they're researching that they
can
very easily and quickly find interviews
with the greatest minds on those
subjects and then
pick it up themselves yeah yeah yeah
what i always wanted to do
is to is to kind of you know rekindle
when you're in college a lot of times
my students yeah i just finished grading
my finals my my students i'm proud to
say nobody failed cosmology this quarter
if you're out there my friends um
everyone did well don't worry i just
submitted the grades if you graduated
yesterday don't worry we're not going to
take back your diploma
at least not for failing my cosmology
class um but the but the fact is
you know a lot of times in college i was
fixated on my grades you know i wasn't
really enjoying it for the sake
of the intellectual journey and i feel
like
we do that a lot we're kind of training
you know british
gentlemen and gentle women of the 1700s
you know to have
all these kinds of different attitudes
and and really not really training them
for a craft or a trade or
or even to go deep and that's fine um
but
i think it's also important to take a
step back and say what makes us uniquely
human
is our consciousness is our humanity is
our imagination
and i started to realize when i
interviewed the late great freeman dyson
i'm like a lot of these guys men and
women that i interview are getting up
there in years
and i have this archival footage of them
yep nine nobel prize winners three
billionaires four astronauts one while
she was on the space station
floating around answering my questions
yeah you know how many chances do people
have to do that and i also like to do
live you know chats with the audience
bring them in because then they get a
chance to interact with these mods and
it's not just me
and we're networking connecting together
this multiverse kind of hive mind and
it's just fun
exactly we can only do this now we
couldn't do what you and i are doing 10
years ago i mean it didn't really exist
it's phenomenal let's take advantage of
it yep i love that point you get
the archival footage of these greatest
minds
and so we've had also people on our show
that have
passed that we've interviewed and so now
it's an honor to have went through the
process of
being able to basically capture a
signature of their individuated
consciousness
and then also i love the bringing in the
audience because then the audience in a
sense gets like their
little five minutes of hey check it out
my question got answered and now i'm on
brian keating's channel
preserved in digital amber for all of
eternity
you know carl sagan who's one of my
great influences i'm sure influences you
he said a book is proof that human
beings can work magic
because you have this long dead author
perhaps like with me and galileo i have
this you know
platonic love affair with galileo and
what he does for me
i hear his voice yeah i don't hear it
literally but wait i'll tell you more
about that later because i am bringing
his voice to life
uh but but we have hear his voice in my
head as i'm reading him
and he's been dead for 400 years almost
so having that kind of connection
carl sagan called magic but how much
more so
if you have their image and their voice
their voice
actually imagine you had galileo
recording with you know
brian no key tango you know back in 1641
or whatever on the uh into the
impossible podcast
now we can do it there's no excuse not
to give it away for free
and just let let the world have it and
see what happens because of it
and you know people say oh well how many
you know why are you doing this you're
just trying to get attention just to get
clicks just a good thing just get my
first of all i'm not if you do a youtube
channel you know to try to make money
it's a it's not the best use of your
time it's there are other ways you could
do you could you could like be a
volunteer and make more money
you do first of all you're at the whim
of an algorithm that you can't control
you're at the whim of people's tastes
and
you're at the whim of how many people
want to watch a particular cat rolling a
ball of yarn up a hill or something like
that
which i often do most of our videos
about black holes get a lot less
views than people dancing on tick tock
exactly you know and there's nothing
wrong with that i'm not going to
complain about that just people are
interested in yeah that's what they're
doing
right now but if you get this niche so
for me it's like to bring together these
minds that people usually
people have books coming out or projects
that they're working on
because when you're like a kid you lose
yourself in these projects and i want to
rekindle that and show
it's not only these theoreticians the
lenny suskins the
max tegmarks the people that you know
similar people you've had on the show
but it's having conversations with
people that are building stuff
that are tinkering with their hands
because i think we're coming back to
that now with this creator economy but
it's going to be creating
things in real life and 3d printing and
ai
and machine learning putting those
things together and looking at data sets
connecting that and maybe even bringing
to life these ancient voices of the past
and those are the kind of passion things
i'm
interested in nowadays yeah that was
actually sparking while you were talking
was
leveraging ai to recreate the faces
and then also recreate the voices as
close as we can
and then really take the the natural
language parsing
of all of the written text and then try
and figure out
the proper structure of
what it would be like if you could query
galileo and then have him
answer back in a way that
could be decentralized disseminated out
to
all of the people on the planet so
there's all these different versions of
galileo and of all the greatest minds of
the past that
you would have never been able to do
anything else besides read the words
like sagan said
of the books and now with all of the ai
and virtual reality and all these cool
things that are
blossoming we can leverage those for
educational purposes totally
something that has been really resonant
for me that i feel like
you touched on that we could potentially
even play with here for a bit would be
how it's almost like one of the main
evolutionary points of the journey of
life
is where the individuated consciousness
stops making it about themselves
and they start making it about other
people and so
that's why you know when you mention
we're not doing this fame not doing this
for money
we're literally doing this not only
because it's so
profoundly cool to be able to be at the
edge of what humans know
but also to be able to capture these
individuated consciousness to
both accumulate to gather to synthesize
and distill and refine their most
profound wisdoms
but to share it for free across the
internet with people
and whatnot and so the simple like
comment
below in the videos where they say wow
this profoundly
augmented my life in some way we live
for that yeah like that is what is
the essence you could say of why we do
this
yeah yeah from my perspective you know
getting to
the see the network effect in action you
know where
you have a network and think about it
you know we could even draw it on your
on your border so if you draw like a
matrix like just an n by n matrix
and this is kind of cool that most
people don't really understand but but
if you draw like a
four by four matrix with four rows four
columns just like a
tic-tac-toe board and um
you know so that has 16 different
elements in it
um and and imagine these are people
so across the top yep there's uh four
people across the top four people across
going vertically four people going
horizontally that means that you might
there's there's 16 different pairs
between people so there's person one
with person two
uh there's person uh there's a person
one yeah so down the diagonal is one one
just call that one one one
now go down the next diagonal is two two
right here yep yep
and then go three three and go four four
now go back up next to one one and call
that one two should we colon these or
it doesn't matter commas are prime yep
now go up there next to the one one
yep and then put that call that one two
next to that one three
one four and now below the next one down
go
call that two three it's the second row
oh no above it is this yep
yep two three and then two four
and then right below that one call that
one three three
four okay so now and then there's a
whole so imagine each one of those
people one two three and four
are the four people so one each person
knows themselves so that doesn't really
count right so one knows himself that's
one one
but one knows two one knows three and
one knows four
now and if you go on the other side the
bottom half of the matrix that's just
two knowing one but that's the same as
one knowing two
so there's really only those six
different pairs now if you were to draw
another element just add one more row on
that matrix you do that now there's five
you're going to see it's going to grow
it's going to increase not as the linear
number it's going to grow as the square
you could you could add a column if you
want yeah add one more column and then
one more row because whatever column you
add you have to add a row
and now imagine you you doubled it
whatever
the number of pairs in other words
number of friends that you could
possibly have
is going to grow as the number of people
squared
yeah exactly so those number of pairs of
connections that are unique are going to
grow
as the upper half of that triangle and
if you remember from
from you know high school math the area
of a triangle goes as the
the base times the altitude of the
triangle
so that means it grows as the area so
that means it grows as the square
so if you double the number of of people
in your network you square the number
you quadruple the number of
connections between those people now
imagine you let's repeat that stat one
more time
so right now we're doing a little bit of
uh analysis of network theory so like
for example if you have like
let's say you have you've moved into a
new city you've moved to new york or
whatever
and let's say when you get there that
you make five friends
and so you have five kind of friends in
maybe the first month or two
and you're like okay well you start
seeing some connections for them but
you're like what would happen if i got
five more
new friends so i introduced them yeah so
now now there are combinations there
where they don't even know you they're
not they're
like two and four are getting together
let's say let's call me number one
looking out for number one so numbers
two and four know each other and now
they're friends and it doesn't even have
anything to do with me
so the number of connections is gonna
grow as your network squared
and they're going to have all these
individual connections without you and
that can go for anything that can go for
facebook friends
it can go you ever get like someone so
let's do that one more time so then
the number of yeah so write down n
capital n
that's the number of of of people in in
the in your group
capital capital n yeah and then that's
the number of people
and then uh next to it or you could put
a comma yeah
and squared is the number of pairings or
friends
so and n to the second power
is the number of connections or pairings
of those people
and what you can start to see imagine
imagine it's like a family imagine that
you have five people
in a house you know husband and wife and
three kids
so now they're all together and they're
doing you know whatever and now they
want to add on
another kid or something like that do
you have to build another house well
maybe but but usually not
but now think about like all the new
connections that you start to build you
actually grow
faster in other words if you imagine
that your happiness is based on
not only your individual relationships
with people how many individual
relationships you have
but their overall wellness is their
connectivity to other people right
so like if your friends are all
anti-social and they don't get along
with people the odds are maybe you're
not gonna have so many friends right
so like in my network some let's say i
interview nine nobel prize we can also
go back to the new york example yeah so
so what happens when you go from having
the five yeah initially to ten
then you'll go from let's say n
connections to n squared and that'll be
like
a hundred different possible connections
new possibilities
possibilities so we're kind of in a
sense we're also then
another sort of way of um of visualizing
this simultaneously
could be something like um
that in the
in the in the tr in the tree of
possibility if you sort of uh
take if you take the initiative to get
to
the oh you can't really can't
but if you if you in the tree of
possibility take the initiative to go to
a specific bifurcation point where you
meet some people
and then from there that opens up that
branches off
yeah yeah you get more yeah more
connections from that
point the key point is that the ratio of
let's say happiness it depends on the
number of total connections that you
spawned or you nucleated in your life
so that goes as n squared but the cost
to you you just had n friends so it goes
as n
squared over n which goes as n in other
words
your happiness in life is going to grow
with the number of connections that you
make
so that can go for friends or can go for
podcast guests so when i have on
you know so many people i'm actually not
only connecting them
like this week i had on delilah gates
she happens to be the second
african-american woman ever to get a phd
from harvard in physics
um she and i now now she's connected to
uh sir roger penrose who won the nobel
prize in 2020 for the discovery of
penrose diagrams penrose singularity
theorem
etc who is connected to stephen hawking
and now you can propagate it not only
concurrently in time but backwards in
time
and you start to develop a very rich
mesh of connectivity it's another kind
of
fabric it's not a fabric of space-time
or material fabric
but it's it's a social network fabric
it's a connectome of the brain of
external brains in other words your
connectome is your own internal wiring
of your brain
but now we were connecting together for
the first time because of the scaling
power of these tools and i've met her in
person
there are people i haven't met in person
that i've interviewed um
you know on the podcast and maybe i'll
never meet them some
some of them i've had on the podcast
that you said are dead now now you can
actually have a connection between
delilah gates
you know who is this wonderful young
woman who's uh going from harvard now
down to princeton
now she has a connection to the freeman
dyson now there are connections there
that can be spawned off and now she can
be connected in that way
so i think it's it's kind of it's almost
like uh
morally imperative for people to take
advantage of these tools now
there is a downside should we make all
the scientists
um have to do kind of this kind of
production definitely not
shouldn't have to do scicomm work but
it's uh
really great to do so and it's really
great when the people that are helping
them do sci-com work
are people that are really good at
they're kind of like the people that
help the sales teams talk to the
engineers at companies
yeah so those are the kind of like cycom
people in a sense
and then there were several things that
were coming up there's like the
connectome that's happening
in our brain and then there's also the
connectome that's happening like
planetarily between the individuated
consciousness
between all these different conscious
agents and so then there's
that massive network theory that's
happening
and the reason why in a sense it's
happening is because you have the
bounding function
as a planet literally if you could like
in a
sandbox style video game if it was
unbounded
if the map was unbounded the conscious
agents would never talk to each other
that would spread out they would spread
out too far and so you've done like open
ai's done all of these
neural mmo rpg style simulations
and the bounding function is mission
critical so the very fact that there's
eight billion of us
bounded on a planet acts like a forcing
function that we
have to interact and engage with each
other and so then that's what creates
all these novel
combinatorics that are endless of people
connecting
finding unique novel insights building
the next cool things that enable us to
do things like stream podcasts
and all this type yeah that's right yeah
so yeah i mean the more connections we
both had on don hoffman who talks a lot
about this so here's an example with him
so he has this theory you know kind of
like this this um
virtual desk type approach to reality
and he kind of has
you know reality is not what it seems um
one of the things that he's most
interested in is like the emergence of
consciousness from
fundamental physics and a predecessor
kind of concept to that is the emergence
of space time itself
you know is space and time are space and
time fundamental or do they emerge from
some other properties
uh recent guest lee smullin and by the
way i don't know how you how do you deal
with like people
because you've had on all these people
uh jordan peterson
joshua bach um don hoffman like you want
to talk about them
and their contributions but then you
know you have trolls out there and they
say oh you're just dropping names like
no i'm not dropping names i'm like i'm
gonna coherently connect
together what their contributions are
don hoffman is interested in nema akani
hamed
at the institute for advanced study so
i'm going to get him on the podcast to
talk about
well his fundamental immersions through
the amplihedron ish you know proposal
that he has that's controversial
for how space and time are emergent you
know not truly a fundamental
property of reality and how that can or
cannot supersede maybe string theory or
something like that anyway i'm curious
do you how do you handle you know kind
of you don't want to overburden the
well if you go back to episode you know
season one uh
any tips for a beginning podcaster in
that sense
like what do you think about that
because you don't want to like just drop
names like i have but i have these
legacy conversations on the one hand
on the other hand every conversation i
want to be fresh new
actionable and useful to a whole new
audience who maybe hasn't seen it you
know a lot of my
initial um off the bat it feels like
you're
doing it exactly perfectly as it is
you know that's been one of the core
sort of like
teachings across the planetary mystic
and spiritual traditions is
just that as it is it is already
perfect and so brian keating
exactly as he's podcasting
is already perfect now does that mean a
new piece of data may come from somebody
that says hey have you tried this other
resource that may be helpful
yeah and it's make it better yeah but
just generally speaking there's so much
time that we pass
in these cycles of depression or anxiety
or
not saying that that's what we were
talking about but that that's a frequent
thing that we do but
that it's sometimes it's just a simple
recognition that me
simply being alive like the very fact
that i exist is itself already worthy
yeah
it's already whole it's already full now
does that
also mean that there's going to be a
beautiful north star
and like a transcendent noble aim that i
that i set my
life towards of course it's also going
to be that but that's the simultaneity
that kicks in
like right now is beautiful and perfect
exactly as it is
yet also we have this transcendent noble
aim that we're
sacrificing the present instant
gratification
for some sort of delayed long-term
selfless goal right yeah and if i think
if the if the if the intention is pure
you know if you're not doing it for
clicks and likes and whatever
which you know as i said before if
you're trying to do that and you're
trying to make money from a channel i
mean there's
many many more easy ways to do it but i
feel like a lot of people that are doing
it don't really have a good metric like
what are they optimizing for i'm a
scientist i'm used to optimization
problems
do i want to optimize you know for cost
or schedule do i want to get it done
fast do i want to get done
for a cheaper budget do i want both do i
want to accomplish a certain scientific
scope do i want to detect
that looks like this this trick looks
like a matrix trade-off exactly what
happens yes you end up doing an
optimization problem mini max
what's the maximum you know the minimum
possibilities exactly
and we go through all these things and
it's so funny you know that you mention
it because like
how you agitate towards perfection
without ever achieving it
but if you give up the agitation you'll
fail completely
right so if i if i think about how we
were planning to build the simon's
observatory get it taking data
um you know say late this year or um
perhaps early
next year and then we make what's called
a risk matrix which is exactly looks
like that
so you have like what could happen what
could go wrong um
and then you multiply what's the
probability that it could go wrong
what's the cost to fix it if it does go
wrong or insure against it going wrong
what's some of the remedies if it does
go wrong and then some of the ways that
you can remedy it after the fact if it
did go wrong
etc so that's called the risk matrix and
nowhere and none of the people that i
know in any experimental astrophysics
program from
largest telescopes space telescopes
ground telescopes what have you
nobody had global pandemic right so then
you ask well is it worth having this
risk matrix if you missed the one in a
century risk that
is the most devastating to the
development of the simon's observatory
the telescope in chile at 5 200 meters
above sea level
isn't that worth like should you just
scrap the whole no you do what you can
and you refine it and then someday
there'll be someone who will
remember hey wait a second back in 2019
2020
didn't they neglect this one little uh
very low
probability event and then didn't that
end up costing them x y and z
so we do learn from it very similar to
the future authoring
programs that like jordan peterson
offers and whatnot and tony robbins
offers
because you you are in 2015 you've
if you go back and look at some of your
notes you'll literally look at
this oh like if i move to this new city
and if i pursue this
greater aim than what i was just in my
local community doing
you know and then you look back five
year and then five years later you look
back and you're like well the reason why
i ended up here was because
i took into account this big matrix of
possibilities
right yeah yeah so i mean my
optimization process has changed a lot
as an early
younger professor graduate student i was
trying to optimize my chances to win a
nobel prize
i'm very candid about that that was
something i uh worshipped in a certain
sense i
sought out um really at the expense of a
great deal of
happiness and internal satisfaction
and it really dominated a lot of my
thought process and um
and i think you know just just being
completely honest
having gone through it i still see it in
a lot of other people
and my hope is that through my book
losing the nobel prize and through some
of the interviews i'm doing with podcast
guests including nine nobel prize
winners and through my upcoming book
that's going to be in my
transcriptions and edited conversations
with the nobel prize winners called
think like a nobel prize winner
that's coming out in september this will
kind of demystify kind of say like
you know to put a short hand on it you
know they put their pants on one leg at
a time
they're ordinary people they have to do
ordinary things
when in science most scientists are not
very into mysticism as i'm sure you've
noted
they're not spiritual and i'm not using
that as a denigration in any way shape
or form i've gone through phases like
that in my life
um but the the point is when you don't
have a religion
i claim that you'll try to find a
religion in some way shape or form
i almost know nobody who has no religion
has no
kind of something that is fundamentally
not provable that's taken upon faith
in science it's often done taken upon
faith these big picture questions
will culminate in recognition among
earthly mortals by a nobel prize
and so i aspire to that for a very long
time i see people aspiring to that now
and even when i teach or when my
colleagues teach you know we talk about
well this experiment was thought about
and this one the nobel prize or this
theory and if you can do this you win a
nobel prize a guest on my show recently
michio kaku
has this god equation book um and i'm
honored to be
associated with him to be giving out uh
he's gonna be winning a big award that i
will be announcing soon or we'll be
announcing soon
um courtesy of the clark center and the
clark foundation
um he you know he's done a tremendous
amount for the world strength
field theory uh et cetera but he has his
book and he's obsessed with the nobel
prize and i you know i'm not sure he's
gonna watch this but if he does
um you know i've talked to him about it
that you put that as the grade
because we are scientists we're used to
being a plus students and getting you
know
and never failing and never getting and
that becomes the grade
i think we're losing sight of the real
goal the real goal is comprehension and
understanding of the cosmos when we're
alive and unable to appreciate it now
some say do we have a right to do that
when there's bigger existential crises
that are facing us
global warming nuclear threats
bioterrorism
all sorts of things some say even things
like alien you know
whatever ufos things like this those
could be existential threats
by what right do we have to study these
questions and yet
i feel these are the things that make us
uniquely human we study the conscious
you know brain that's what we're trying
to comprehend is how do we fit into the
universe
and we are the only creature that we
know about that has a conscious
ability to comprehend that we live in a
universe as comprehensible and that as
einstein said
is the most incomprehensible thing about
the universe that's right yeah
so i would take that last bit
and i would pose what i would say
is the most upstream solution
to all that is downstream which is that
you can't study without knowing
the instrument itself so you're
basically
perpetually overlooking consciousness or
awareness to study form
and you can't do that
properly without understanding
the instrument itself that you're using
to study the form but how deep do you
have to go there
because you know i always feel like
these questions of well free will
and you know is anybody i'll just i'll
just give you the most utilitarian
reason right yeah because you also gave
this list of all these styles of like
sustainable development goals
style eradicating suffering meeting
basic needs this type of stuff
well in on the analysis of the
instrument
itself consciousness awareness itself in
that analysis
one becomes more sovereign
in their own peace and joy
and then they're able to at a deeper
level understand the same
unconditional love for the entire cosmos
that these major mystical figures have
talked about before
that underlying fabric of unity like all
coming from the same source like you
can't argue and say that like i came
from a different big bang than you came
from
and so basically the same comprehension
the universe comprehending itself
is what is shared among us the potential
to do it right i mean there are some
people that as we know will watch the
tick tock videos and the aspiration to
do it is not in their kin
that's not something they're concerned
with so i always wonder though when
people say
you know like carl sagan you know the
majesty of the universe is encapsulated
in the grain of dust or you know
when you look up at clouds on jupiter
you know do you feel like oh i'm really
i'm really akin to that because you know
i
make methane and jupiter's made of
methane i i find it hard to believe that
i would feel that kind of kinship the
way i would with a with a puppy
or even a cockroach like today i was
walking by i almost stepped on a
cockroach
and i i sound so weird alan but i felt
compassion for this freaking cockroach
because i've been thinking so much about
artificial intelligence lately and
something like you know that michio
kaka actually said he's like ai like
people are like totally delusional
we're not even at the point like it's
barely like a cockroach level like it
can't do
anything that we yes it can do things
faster it can use bad statistics
machine learning it can do funny dances
and robots that look scary or whatever
but it's not really intelligent because
it's really inculcated
with the intelligence of its creator and
so he got me thinking about cockroaches
and i swear i almost stepped on a
cockroach i felt like i was like killing
a puppy but i didn't step on i didn't
kill it
and i'm like i feel more kinship with
that cockroach than i do with the planet
jupiter
so yeah the creation source the big bang
i mean how far
remote like how far do you want to
stretch it yeah let's just keep it close
right so most of us have families and we
have kids
and so if we have families and kids what
we're typically used to is
extending out this feeling of
unconditional love
to our nuclear family yeah and then
much of what is taught in spirituality
and mysticism
are simply extending
the unconditional love beyond the family
to the community into the world
at large and then to the whole cosmos so
basically turning the universe itself
into your own body
and in doing so then you have that same
feeling like what you described with the
cockroach
you begin having that same feeling
towards life itself
oh certainly towards life i'm not
arguing about life i'm not even arguing
about plant life or
but i'm i'm arguing about inert things
nebulae the big bang
unconscious beings as far as we know at
least so we don't communicate with but
like most
practically for like average people in
the world they want to know okay
so if i am going to make an analysis of
a cell in biology
or if i'm going to begin studying
subatomic particles in physics
uh maybe what does it mean for me to
also
become aware of awareness itself or
aware of consciousness like
what does it mean to become aware of the
instrument itself sure yeah
and might in my analysis of that process
when like a trigger comes up like your
mom
or your dad or your brother or your
spouse or your kid or whatever
says something and immediately you
you react and get upset and like the
whole thing happens
maybe what is then taught through these
traditions
is something like equanimity where you
can basically train this
emptiness where you see this trigger
come and it's like the sensitivity
to see the trigger come create a
sensation
in this web of the chemoelectric
connectomix we were talking about
earlier
and then you basically watch it dissolve
rather
than react that massive cascade of anger
and then what you're left with
is again the peace and the joy and then
you're basically regaining
sovereignty and you're regaining that
then
strengthening the unconditional love
with your family and beyond
and so there's this deep practicality
not only in when you go out and study
form afterward
but also in your moment-to-moment
experience suffering less being less
depressive being less
anxious sure yeah yeah i mean there's
kind of a totality to it especially when
i'm here
when i have the the pleasure of being in
los angeles up from san diego
sometimes on a dark night driving home
and you're you know coming over a
mountain or something here
and you look out or flying into lax or
something like that
and it's almost impossible for for a
human being
even if you look up at all the stars in
the night sky if you go out to the
desert go out to joshua tree
go out to wherever you want here you
could on the human eye can only see
about 6 000
individual discrete stars right but
you're flying into lax or you're coming
over on the
mountains of tapanga canyon whatever
you're doing a drive at night here
i urge people to do that you look out
you see tens of millions of discrete
lights
now imagine each one of those is a
little soul there's a human being
responsible for that light in that light
then i can feel
excessive compassion in other words the
avatar for the for the individual soul
or spirit that's there
i can feel a love towards i could feel
that but to to say that oh well the
quarks that make that person up i should
also
no because for me then i start to think
well do i have compassion for a virus
do i have like is it the constituents no
it's organized
form it's the assembly it's the d
entropy
of the process that the organizational
structure of the process
and the more complex it is and the more
finely assembled it is the harder it is
to represent
um in a simple equation the less
compressible something is i think a
human being is infinitely
complex and also complicated in other
words like a 747
is really uh complicated because it
takes a lot of parts it would take uri a
long time to build it we could build it
given all the parts and the right
machinery but it's not complex
in that it requires an infinite amount
of information to encapsulate what it is
like white noise is complex or
pi could be you know pi is not complex
but in other words it's not computable
so in this sense for me it's harder to
relate to the
abstract kind of pan cyclist approach to
reality or consciousness
and i do you know i'm on practical i'm
an experimentalist so i like to build
stuff and you're talking about the the
sensory organ
and and sensing itself so i've become
very interested lately on these
questions of the
you know in terms of origin of the
universe is there a way to specify
the sensory organ the sensory apparatus
the sensory laws
at the time of the beginning if indeed
there was a beginning
and if there wasn't can you represent
that and typically this goes by the name
of the wheeler dewitt equation or some
you know pan cosmic conscious not
conscious pan
quantum mechanical wave function so this
is
orthodox quantum mechanics that exist in
in various versions of
even alternatives to things like string
theory called loop quantum gravity i'll
have a video about that hopefully this
week
you know kind of a primer on on on what
loop quantum gravity is as an
alternative to string theory why it's
important
but one of the foundations of it is this
wheeler dewitt equation
which is really saying you have a wave
function let's not get into what that
means but you know symbolically there's
some
entity that surmises all the different
particles energies fields forces and so
forth in the universe
and then there's some dynamical law or
operator that operates on that
but my question is where does that come
from like does the math
predate the universe do we have to think
about who created the math
uh even absent the mind you know behind
it like an intelligent designer i'm not
going to argue
one way or another but do you need the
math do you not need the math
to make these predictions about the
sensory organs as you know
in quantum mechanics you can't make a
non-destructive measurement of many
different
processes that we call important or
interesting collapse of the wave
function
you know uh heisenberg uncertainty
principle these are destructive
measurements
so so too with the brain can you imagine
measuring the wave function of the brain
is that even conceivable
but even more simple than that
elementary than that is the wave
function of the universe
where does that exist does it exist in a
mind where does mathematics exist
sometimes i say to my friends you know
like does a triangle
exist i'll ask you does a triangle exist
can you give me a triangle so
wouldn't another approach to this
same line of thinking
be that the
universe is a
mechanism for exploration and
for comprehension of infinite
possibility
and so there isn't a something
outside of what the universe is
that acts as a
top-down force it is
simply we are the force
we are the very force that we're looking
for
so as in the universe itself
is the way that we sort of design
the process of comprehending infinite
possibility
so we we use the universe
as a reality design mechanism to
comprehend
infinite possibility so we are
it there's this is what is called
non-duality
there's no dualism there's no separation
between yourself and the absolute or
yourself in the highest
you are the highest you are it
we are it and that we use this style
of reality design and exploration of
infinite possibility
as the highest to play to explore
and so this is like a late this is like
a later stage or advanced stage of
mysticism or spirituality but it plays
very well
with science it's not like signs of
spirituality
are not separate things they're actually
one thing
that then we create an illusory barrier
between and separate
and so you when you merge the two
together
and you sort of do the process of what
you know when brett weinstein was
moderating sam harris and jordan
peterson
in conversation you know brett was
talking about this also as a sorting
algorithm
and so in a sense your the analogy
that's been used for a long time is you
drain the dirty bath water
and then you take the clean baby and so
this we also talked about this in in
high level perception which is the first
visual distillation that we made
and that you want to archive the dogma
and the fundamentalism from the world
religions but in
science you also want to archive the
perverse
incentives that exist that you also
write about losing the nobel prize
and you want to retain the beauty of the
scientific method and
reproducibility replicability you want
to retain of spirituality
what is simply called like we talked
about earlier
is well how do i reduce my suffering how
do i have more peace how do i have more
joy
just a very simple stuff but also what
is called you know mysticism or yoga
is just simply becoming one with god or
the absolute or divine
and that process of union is most
typically just
a turn inwards rather than what you're
perpetually overlooking
is consciousness itself is awareness
itself it's so profound
the fact that you have this power to
know and that we share
this power to know like the universe a
product of the universe
is the power to know that then can like
turn on itself and be like
dude what did we just make a universe to
like play and explore
and but we like overlook it we're like
ah consciousness isn't that cool
yeah oh it's yeah it's just woo-woo
stuff
yeah i mean my issue with it is you know
people get
attracted to the kind of hardcore
science brass tacks let's measure these
things let's build these satellites
blast off these rockets and that's all
great and i love that
and i'm inspired by that and i do that
but on the other hand
you know what scientists are really good
at are the how
questions you know how does this
reaction take place how did the first
elements on the periodic table get
formed
how did these photons you know interact
with matter
that comprise the cosmic microwave
background radiation
and maybe the what you know what is the
universe made of what's the curvature of
space and time
but what we really care about as human
beings is the why
you know it's like your kid asks you you
know like can i do this why
why not why not and the ultimate answer
is always because like you can't tell
them
the reason there's no answer other than
because um in this case you can't you
know and i i made this analogy
you know i was talking with freeman
dyson you know late great freeman dyson
was the first guest on my podcast
and you know i was asking well you you
don't call yourself an atheist but
you're not like
practicing and he's like um you know so
how do you reconcile your religion and
your science
he's like well religion uh is talking
about god which is a great
mystery and science is about like
solving puzzles like a puzzle
and a mystery are different things
they're categorical different classes
like a puzzle is like a rubik's cube
or a crossword puzzle like i might not
be good at that
like my mom is awesome at solving
crossword puzzles i'm just terrible at
them
my kid can solve a rubik's cube i can
solve it too but i'll take it apart you
know whatever
um but other things are mysteries and
mysteries may or may not be solvable by
any human being right
so i always joke you know my job is to
turn as many mysteries into puzzles as i
can
while i can and i think that's the why
versus how or why versus
what uh and the meaning questions come
from the why
are wrestling with the why you know my
religion is judaism
and that the word israel in the hebrew
language means to fight
against god it's a very interesting word
right like you think oh like jews are
really you know they're like worship god
worship god no the divine
no you're fighting with god you're
asking questions you're wrestling i
don't believe that let me struggle let
me
and that's the whole socratic talmudic
method that we've been you know
kind of heir to for thousands of years
um
but they but the question is when do you
stop when does that turn off and
one of my friends james altucher is a
famous writer podcaster himself he said
you know
kids stop laughing you know they they
laugh like 300 times a day when they're
five years old and adults we laugh
you know five times a day for lucky so
somewhere along the top way there's like
a 60-fold
attrition factory where's that where
does that go and uh
we were talking the other day and i'm
just like yeah but you know when you're
a kid you cry over everything
and as you're an adult you don't cry
about almost anything except if
you know it's really bad so i guess you
know there's a trade-off of these two
different these two different emotions
but the bottom line is how do you you
know kind of recapture that or what
when do we lose the the asking the why
questions and only focus on the how
questions as scientists
that's something that you know i'm
really obsessed with is how do we
how do we get to the why more often than
just the how
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
share with you what i feel like is
really relevant for what we're talking
about right now so
what we have is you know this is on
highlevelperception.com which is like i
said that first visual distillation that
we did
and so what we have are if you go under
designs
right so first thing is that this is
that sorting algorithm visualization
right so when you drain the dirty bath
water from two different things and then
you uplift the baby and you synthesize
it together into one like science and
spirituality
or another common one is individualism
and collectivism
or another common one is the left and
right politically in the lewis or the
u.s and china or what have you you can
do this
endlessly so there's you know there's
that style visualization and then the
other one that you were just mentioning
which
is uh this one's called the edge and in
this one
the idea is very similarly to what you
were saying is
we're basically over time undergoing a
process of continuously pushing the
edge of what is known and then though
it's where all of these different
puzzles and all these different
you're basically planting a little flag
beyond the edge and you're like that's
our hypothesis
let's do scientific method style
experiments
to prove it and then and then as you do
boom boom boom you push out the edge
further and now like we showed in this
network
theory example boom now a new just like
you know satoshi nakamoto publishes the
bitcoin white paper in 2008 and now all
of a sudden
13 years later you're like it's this
fractal of
cryptocurrencies and decentralization
technologies and insanity that's emerged
and so this is the these are the styles
of visualizations and processes
that can sort of help people understand
what we're talking about
but yet simultaneously there's a
if you're not going to start with the
and this is this is visualized here
quite simply
if you're not going to start with this
which is like you know the magic trick
if you're not gonna start
with the question of okay ha
ha ha this is a universe and ha
ha ha we're humans on some planet
orbiting a star
haha okay but why are we here right like
come on
like i'm i'm going to play this game but
i want to know why
and so then you can just do simple
things
like make
the what science may say is ah this is a
big
this is a big leap this is a big jump
but really
if you turn inward you can come to the
un understanding of this
which is that this is
a conscious singularity this is infinite
oneness
this is one infinite creator endlessly
expressing itself
and using a universe and fractaled out
as individuated consciousness
to be able to explore and understand
yeah i guess
for me the challenge is when you get to
uh
incompatible hypotheses so let's take
um general relativity and
um and the hypothesis of a new planet
inbound of the planet or inward of the
planet mercury
so just for the listeners that might be
not so clear um
back in the 1700s it was noticed that
the the planet uranus
was moving in a strange way and there
was an astronomer by the name of la
verrier
who was observing this planet's motion
nearness this
uh planet just beyond the orbit of about
twice the distance from saturn
uh from the earth as saturn and uh he
noticed it was behaving very strangely
and he said maybe there's another planet
pulling on
this planet uranus and that's causing
its motion to move
and we can't see it but if i look at
historical data tables
i'll be able to determine where it was
in the past if it's just a chunk of dark
matter
literally a chunk of dark matter which
is uranus
which is neptune later found to be
called neptune he predicted it based on
the laws of universal gravitation
predicted by
uh none of than isaac newton so in other
words using newton's laws
applied to the strange anomalous
behavior of the planet uranus
he predicted the observation of dark
matter in the form of neptune
unobserved planet and then we observed
it it's not dark it reflects the light
of the sun
but it's so faint and so small you can't
see unless you know exactly where to
look which he provided
then he said let me turn my telescope on
the planet mercury
which also behaves strangely so it's
orbiting and its orbit is advancing
slightly too much per year
than it should be if newton's laws of
gravity behave the way
that we expect them to and they seem to
hold over the course of the entire
universe
hence they're called the law of
universal gravitation
he said huh you know i knew i was right
the first time i proposed a new planet
back you know when i proposed neptune
let me propose a new one called vulcan
and vulcan orbits on the other side of
the sun from us
so we can never see it but it pulls
gravitationally on the planet
mercury and it's locked just the same
way we only see the one side of the
earth
of the moon so too with mercury so we'd
never see it but it would pull it
of course we now know that that's
completely wrong the reason that
mercury's orbit behaves so anomalously
is because of the curvature of space
that's warped by the presence of
gravitational mass in the form of the
sun
courtesy of albert einstein so the
theory of general relativity so
in one case you would say well the guy's
brilliantly right he proposed this one
solution this hammer
he had a hammer he hit the nail on the
head with neptune uh and then he tries
to apply it again so he was right
and then he tries to apply the same
exact tool the same sensor as you were
saying earlier
to the exact same type of problem it's
just a planet behaving badly
but he's totally wrong so do you say
that those are just two manifestations
of the same
consciousness or the same truth one is
right and one is wrong so
in other words we can't do anything with
vulcan but we can do something with
neptune
so he was right and wrong on that front
but we don't use the wrong
part at all and we only keep the right
part so how do you
reconcile those two or another way to
phrase this is how does the universe
understand itself yeah or get to the
truth or whatever that means yeah yeah
and so well what um sensor
does the universe use to understand
itself
and what would your answer be to that
well i'm saying based on observation
yeah and so but what is yeah so what is
who what is the observer
like what is that yeah or another way to
say this who is that
are we talking about ourselves are we
talking about consciousness
are we talking about awareness is this
saying what is used to understand the
universe
you could say that you know both like
you can say isaac asimov said something
like this he said
if you say the earth is flat you're
wrong if you say the earth is a perfect
sphere
you're wrong technically you're wrong it
actually bulges a little bit at the
equator it's flattened a little bit at
the poles because the earth was
molten and spins and it distorts right
and it's plate tectonics so you're wrong
but who's more wrong
so are you allowed to say you know
according to the same score if you're in
the same framework
that the flat earth is wrong and the and
the bulge earth is right or and the
spherical earth is right or where where
where do you draw the line who gets to
say that you know it's not scientific
progress to say the earth is actually
closer to round than it is to plot
like who gets to be the judge i would
say it's judged on observation which is
why
i run into problems with things that are
in principle unobservable like i study
the multiverse
you know how do you judge the efficacy
the accuracy
the uh applicability of something like
the multiverse which may be
impossible even in pr in principle or
even in theory to observe
in other words a parallel universe
existing contemporaneously or maybe not
in space or in time or both um these are
fascinating questions which
we may never be able to answer and and
yet we've been
faced with such things before you know
steady state universe versus a big bang
we never thought although if you asked
einstein in 1915 could you you know
prove that the universe had an origin he
would have said you're stupid there is
no origin of the universe universe is
basically static
and then 14 years later he was disproved
of the disabuse of that notion
so i guess my question is yeah i mean is
there do you get to have a rubric do you
get to have a metric
and say relativity is better than
newton's gravity
um you know the curvature of space is
better than
than planet vulcan okay so we could even
just
go to a very simple fundamental which is
do you prefer happiness peace
joy do you prefer that or do you prefer
suffering
depression i do but i know people who
don't right and so so now we're just
doing a pretty hap
like a pretty happy versus depressed
style
juxtaposition and when we do that and
then we say
okay let's say out of eight billion
people
the 7.9 or whatever you know and by
besides the trolls
say that they prefer to be happy rather
than depressed
and so now you would say okay well
what's our like you were indicating
earlier
what is the general rubric that we can
potentially civilizationally agree on
is an optimized way for us to use this
instrument of consciousness of awareness
to become more sensitive to guiding us
towards happiness and towards joy and
towards peace and away from suffering
and so it's it's both it's always both
it's always simultaneous where it's both
this sovereign
style of like we gave earlier that
example with trigger
and yet it's also meeting basic needs
because when the basic needs are met
it's much easier for you
to also not need to be
anxious and survival instinct roaring
all the time
and so you have the simultaneity where
you have
the the saliency and the importance of
the analysis of form and leveraging that
to maximize human potential
mission critical and yet simultaneously
the turn inward
and the true analysis of the very unit
the very vehicle the very instrument
that the universe uses
to observe and to interpret and to
understand to comprehend
and so when you do both of those
simultaneously that's kind of the
spirituality and the science
and merge together into one and then you
say the instrument do you mean human
like homo sapiens or do you mean just
yeah yeah i agree with you
actually ellen but there are people who
will say well how do you know how do you
know the cockroach that i was so
gracious and
and beneficent towards uh didn't step on
today how do you know that that con that
cockroach doesn't have consciousness
and the dog in the cat clearly does
or the bonobo yeah experience
right clearly sure exactly yeah so so is
that
less of an experience of consciousness i
i think so
but um but how do you answer people like
that that say well you clink because you
can build
a sensor that you can cool down to
absolute zero take to the edge of space
in the south pole or in the atacama
desert
that because of that it's superior you
know you're only here because
you know the homo sapiens killed up the
denisovans and they have slightly
denser connect homes or whatever um i
personally don't find that very
uh you know very sentient yeah that
doesn't bother me so much
that that we're here and we're able to
appreciate because as you say you know
you can wonder about why we're wondering
about why we're wondering about stuff
or you can say well let me actually try
to make progress
and and make some something meaningful
and i think victor frankel said it well
you know the
search for meaning is is second only to
you know
food and the maslow hierarchy of need
and physical safety
it's really only second to that and some
people it's above even you know
other desires that they have uh for fame
and for wealth
and things like that so i think you know
having an actual
meaning in one's life and and the more
that you have meaning i think the more
fulfillment that you can have um
and to me yeah these questions it's just
funny because some of the deepest
meaning i have is for him and
trying to wrestle with questions that
may never be answered right
and i think that's the deliciousness of
love yeah
because we simultaneously
must humble ourselves
to the extent at which we understand
that we're part of an infinite mystery
correct yet also be willing to
perpetually go deeper and deeper in our
understanding
of what this reality is
and why we're even here and that process
and so
that's why this turn inward and becoming
really strong at that
while also the manipulation of form and
maximizing the
basic needs being met and this type of
stuff like those two being merged
together into one
seems to be one of the pinnacle recipes
for that
and it also is like one of the most
interesting things about the turn inward
is that once you get to the
more kind of advanced non-dual stages
of awareness
when your sense of identity has shifted
from like
a separate person like i'm this atlas
allen
unit of life rather than being a
separate unit of life i become the
actual universe itself
i am that itself that
then this style of like barrier
or separation between the two
individuated units
it dissolves more and more so i begin
radiating like the sun does like the sun
does not discriminate
and begin serving with its unconditional
love light that provides the planet with
its life
it does not discriminate and it's just
the cloudy
perception of the human itself
that makes it in its expression
not be able to see the sunlight essence
that is what is omnipresently
always already free and there and you
only see in humans the ability to reject
you know a purpose like an animal
doesn't have the luxury
of rejecting you know its uh its
its basic biological needs in other
words it has a need
to feed itself and to feed its young or
you know whatever biological
imperatives it has um it can't ignore
those
even a dog you know like it will show
love
and and it's funny in hebrew the word
for dog means
similar to love the word actually means
it is like being loved in some sense
some translation of that isn't that
interesting like
a dog loves you you know and it looks
like that you know and it will
behave like that but you know obviously
you don't treat it well it shouldn't
behave like that right
but human beings have this ultimate kind
of luxury that we can
ignore this unique thing that we have in
other words a dog has to you know the
wild dog has to take care of its
its needs it doesn't can't just like
make puppy eyes at some owner and get
fed right it has to go and dig into the
garbage and eat food
but a human being has the only animal
that has the luxury
to not have to do that like in other
words to not have to think about the
grand questions of existence
or to squander as it's uh the precious
few moments of life that it's given and
and to even deny that it's meaningful
or to deny the rea the value of other
people that's what really gets me
you know i was thinking the other day
people were talking so much about um
about artificial intelligence alien life
and they said i want to ask you
actually they said you know tomorrow uh
they discover alien life uh it's proven
you know there's some talk about ufo
whatever
we we confirm 100 scientific evidence
there is an
uh alien life on some planet we can
detect um we can detect
easily detect it um what what um
what do you think the next day what
happens is the world change does the
world stay the same
what do you personally think the analogy
is just like what we just went through
which is that
when you quote become more awakened or
become more enlightened or you gain more
of what the greatest mystics or sages
have talked about
that this so-called barrier between
the units of life dissolves more and
more
right yeah so it's the same thing with
the planet and with another
planet yes is the barrier dissolves more
and more
that the life that is birthed on another
rock orbiting a star
is not different than it's beautiful
it's the same universe but it's also
beautiful in its difference in the sense
that
it's although it's the same awareness or
the same
consciousness that we're talking about
and it's most pure or bare state
beneath everything here it's also cool
that our costumes are different
yes yes we all interact differently and
so that's the unity and diversity
simultaneously
or another way of visualizing that is
just like the the life that is birthed
on the different planets brian's got to
go soon
so we're going to get him out here in a
moment
it's the similar thing with life on
different planets
yes so the unity of the universe
but the unique diversity that is birthed
on the different planets
because it's going to be a different
vehicle of sentience
yeah i think though you know we already
know what's going to happen
because we've seen this over and over
again on earth we see species going
getting rid of
you know if you found a cockroach on
mars that would be like
headlines all over the world right in
other words something that's that
advanced
and i look at um you know when i see a
bonobo
or you know capuchin monkey or we have
like 99.9
similar genetics to them i'm not talking
about like a slime mold on the ice cave
of europa
i'm talking about like 99 like right on
go to africa and go and meet one or go
to the san diego zoo
you'll meet one of them right and yet we
devastate them we destroy them and like
we don't care about them
we're going to care more we're going to
feel better about ourselves and our
humanity
we find that there's a slime mold on the
planet you're on the planet jupiter's
moon europa i doubt it i
so i'm less sanguine look at the history
of the 20th century what was done to our
people
you know in different in different
instantiations throughout throughout the
last
100 years plus it's awful the human
being's record of self-reflection and
majesty
is quite bad that's why i look at it and
say well who is the judge like of the
you know who sets the
agenda for what counts as a conscious
agent because does the concentration
have to be good does it have to agitate
for goodness happiness
equanimity and all the wonderful things
that you say i agree with you
i think a healthy person does but
there's a lot of unhealthy
kind of vitriol in the world as
evidenced by just you know pick up the
newspaper
and and so i do think about that i worry
about you know humanity and i think it's
almost a fantasy and i talked to my com
you know my colleagues in chemistry and
biochemistry
um uh seti you know people they think
it's just gonna be this huge
breakthrough and people are gonna go you
know wild in the stream there's gonna be
peace and love and i'm like go down to
the beach
scoop up a handful of you know of cr of
sand crabs or whatever
like there's your life like you don't
have to go out and sear i'm not saying
don't go believe me i'm an
astrophysicist now i'm searching for
all the mysteries of the universe that i
can possibly answer i'm not saying don't
do it
but don't delude yourself that you're
gonna find meaning in it necessarily if
you do find
there's a biomarker out in space or
something like that i'm talking on
wednesday with adam frank
who wrote a wonderful book called light
of the stars he's a professor at
university of rochester
works for npr and many other sites and
he's talking about looking for alien
civilizations not by their
radio signals or their atomic bombs or
their spacecraft but looking for
the effects of global warming that's
produced on their planets in other words
when we created agriculture as homo
sapiens
that led to a changing of our climate on
a global scale
and he thinks that could be done on
another planet we can look for the
telltale signs of the civilization by
looking for chemical signals in their
atmosphere so that's wednesday morning
on my channel
yeah the nasa and seti folk have called
it the exoplanet biosignature correct
which is really interesting okay yeah to
wrap
could we potentially call
reality a
manifestation of infinite possibility
um i mean you can call it what you like
i feel like it's it's reality is
subject to so many definitions that to
me
as an experimental scientist it's
frustrating in other words
i can talk about perception i can talk
about sensors
i had this conversation with deepak
chopra and with with don hoffman
yeah and and the question is what
interacts with a sensor you know how do
you perce
perceive it can you detect a soul can
you detect does that mean that
things that are not detectable now are
forever not detectable
that's the question i don't think a
scientist would say in the affirmative
so these are interesting topics i think
that there are far enough removed from
my ability to define them
that i spend most of my time thinking
about the question rather than trying to
come up with that answer
i feel like the level of resonance with
that
is pretty much what science
logicians girdles etc have been for the
longest time
being like yeah this is pretty much
where science and spirituality overlap
that the universe is a manifestation of
infinite possibility you'll never come
to the end of infinite possibility
that's why it's infinite possibility and
the universe is a manifestation
of that explorative essence of what the
true nature
is and we use these conscious agents
as the mechanism to be able to do set
exploration of infinite possibility i
feel like that's where the overlap is
and that that's where this next 100
years and
beyond is really going to be focused you
know
the thing i point out all the time is
that you know computers are wonderful
assistive devices they enable our world
they
help us dramatically however they don't
uh they lack the ability to comprehend
the infinite in other words when you
ask a computer to do something uh
infinite like it will approximate
infinity by a large number divided by a
very small number its largest capable
number divided by its smallest capable
number but that's not really infinity by
an infinite amount that's off by an
infinite amount
so how how close could it actually get
to describing
um not just an infinitesimal point like
a like a
like a zero dimensional object could it
describe a singularity
could it describe the origin of the
universe if indeed there was a
singularity
can it comprehend no i think maybe
perhaps we'll find that only a human
brain
only a human brain can comprehend the
infinite and that to me would be
astounding
such a good way to wrap beautiful i love
it
brian this has been a fantastic round
it's great to be with you it's great to
be in person my first podcast local live
and
i'll be back in la my brother great to
meet you i'm so so
pumped i'm so pumped for these rounds
they're so strong
and it's a really great vibe on that
both the into the impossible vibe of
interviewing
so many great minds and then also
becoming more and more of a polymath and
disseminating that to the public
and also the links are in the bio below
to brian's channel
go and subscribe to the channel and
check out his massive catalog of
interviews
and also the links below to his website
you can find his book there
as well as you can go and give him a
follow on twitter and instagram and
whatnot
and also let us know your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode in
general we would love to hear from you
like the video rank it up in the algo
subscribe if you haven't yet to the
channel
and also share the video with other
people that you feel like it would
resonate with
because these are the types of
conversations that
will hopefully be further making
relatable distillations to the masses
around the core essence of science of
spirituality weaving those two together
these types of things how to make
people's lives practically better how to
make the collective practically better
yeah beautiful beautiful simple stuff
love you everyone thank you for tuning
in thanks again thank you
thanks again brian cool all right much
love peace everyone
you